strontium-90 is a radioactive isotope
that undergoes beta decay
because radioactive decay is a first
order process radioactive isotopes have
constant half-lives
half-life is symbolized by t1 half and
it's the time required for one half of a
sample of a particular radioactive
isotope to decay
for example the half-life of
strontium-90
is equal to 28.8
years
let's say we start with 10 grams of our
strontium
90 radioactive isotope
and on the y-axis we're going to put the
mass of our strontium isotope in grams
and on the x-axis we're going to have
time so when time is equal to
zero
we have 10 grams of our isotope
since the half-life of strontium-90 is
28.8 years if we wait
28.8 years we'll go from 10 grams to 5
grams so the next point on our graph
would be at 5 grams
and this time should be 28.8
years
if we wait another
28.8 years we're going to go from 5
grams to half of that which would be 2.5
grams so the next point would be here
at 2.5
if we wait another 28.8 years we go from
2.5 grams down to
1.25 so approximately here
on our graph
so this graph shows
exponential
decay
let's say we were asked to find out how
much of our radioactive isotope of
strontium is left after
115.2 years
so what we would do is take
115.2 years and divide that by the
half-life of 28.8
years and by doing that we realize that
115.2
is really just four half-lives
so one approach to this problem will be
starting with our 10 grams and we think
about one height one half life taking us
to 5 grams another half-life taking us
to 2.5 another half-life taking us to
1.25
and then finally one more half-life that
takes us to 0.625
grams so just doing the problem this way
we can see that's one two three four
half-lives so our final answer is
0.625 grams remain after 115.2 years
another approach to do the same problem
would be to start with our 10 grams and
we multiply that by one half to get the
amount remaining after one half-life and
we could do that three more times to get
the amount that remains after four
half-lives we could have also have
written this as 10 times
one-half to the fourth power since we
needed to wait four half-lives
all these approaches will get you the
answer of 0.625 grams of our radioactive
isotope remaining after
115.2 years
for a chemical reaction with reactant a
that's first order the rate law says
that the rate of reaction is equal to
the rate constant k times the
concentration of a
to the first power
since radioactive decay is a first order
process we can write that the rate of
decay is equal to the rate constant k
times
n to the first power where n is the
number of radioactive nuclei in a sample
since radioactive decay is a first order
process we can also use this equation
for the rate constant which comes from
first order kinetics which says that the
rate constant k is equal to 0.693
divided by the half-life
for example if we wanted to find the
rate constant for the radioactive decay
of strontium 90
the rate constant would be equal to
0.693
divided by the half-life of strontium-90
which we saw was 28.8
years
so when we do that math we find that k
is equal to
0.0241
1 over years
another equation from first order
kinetics is the integrated rate law for
a first order reaction and the
integrated rate law says that the
natural log of the concentration of
reactant a at some time t is equal to
negative kt plus the natural log of the
initial concentration of reactant a
since we're using n which is the number
of radioactive nuclei in our sample
instead of the concentration of a we can
write the integrated rate law for a
first order radioactive decay process
which says the natural log of the number
of radioactive nuclei at some time t
is equal to negative kt plus the natural
log of the initial number of radioactive
nuclei so let's say we start with 1.000
grams of our strontium 90 radioactive
isotope and our goal is to find out how
much remains after two years
so we're going to wait two years and
find out how much of our radioactive
isotope remains
so we're going to use our equation for
the integrated rate law
let's go ahead and plug in what we know
we already know what k is we found that
in our earlier problem so we can write
this is equal to negative times k which
is
2
.024
1.
next we also know the time period we're
interested in so we know what t is t is
two years so let's go ahead and write
2.00 in here for the time
next we're going to add the natural log
of the
initial number of radioactive nuclei in
our sample and while we don't have the
initial number we do have the mass and
since the mass is proportional to the
number of radioactive nuclei it's okay
to go ahead and plug that into our
equation so we're going to plug in the
natural log of one
and all of this is equal to the natural
log of the initial number of radioactive
nuclei at some time t so we have the
natural log of that
the natural log of one is zero so now we
have the natural log of n
is equal to
and when we do this math we're going to
get negative .0482
next we have to get rid of the natural
log and we can do that by taking e to
both sides so if we take e to both sides
the natural log cancels out and we get
that
n is equal to
.953
grams so that's how much of our
radioactive isotope remains
after two years